easiest way to ask for someone's number  who you're networking with or a girl  that you're trying to ask out at a bar  is to ask this question after a quick  exchange to say hey would it be totally  overstepping for me to ask you for your  number so we can exchange info and the  thing is is when you ask someone if  you're totally overstepping we're trying  to get them to say is no and people feel  much safer saying no and so you're  asking hey would you totally  overstepping exchange numbers should be  like no and all of a sudden you get the  number it's much easier to say that then  hey can you give me your number all of a  sudden it sounds way more ascii and way  more weird whereas hey would be totally  over something for us to exchange digits  all of a sudden it sounds way easier and  way more laid back and that's how i've  done it for years